we've been together for a little bit
over 10 years yeah it's been a minute
we've never made lunch for each other I
don't even like really a real lunch for
me issues like any sort of mix of like
grilled chicken and quinoa not really
hard to make I also like Wendy's a lot I
think the hardest part is gonna be
choosing what to make for her because
she's a lot more finicky of an eater
than I am my mom never gave me notes in
my lunch so I would probably try and do
something like that
I just got it's my job to sustain you
here you are enjoy this sandwich
I think what's cool about packing a
lunch for someone who you don't see like
all day necessarily is you get to like
really think to yourself that wow this
person took a minute to really like put
themselves in my shoes and try and
figure out what it is I like let's go
get some groceries
pack up our lunch let's build these bad
boys are about to pick up some groceries
for the rest of the week
so we have a sandwich it looks great
it looks like 10 tried to panini press
this which is awesome got our sandwich
with 15 grams of mail three slices a
turkey one slice of tomato two slices of
Colby jack cheese it's got these like
you know toasted marks as protein fat
carbs fiber
we have five rhesus mini cops go booth
probably her all-time favorite candy
come over here where you out right now
all right so just stay in there whoa day
one in the bag this is like everything I
want in a lunch okay so since wasa teas
mentioned never receiving any notes in
her lunch of the child I've copied these
multi colored index cards because that's
how my mom's used to do it this is the
cutest note I just finished my entire
lunch and I still can't get over how
cute this note is is this like a double
death oh man this is like a double
attack or PB&J perfect ratio the ten is
going out to shoot something today so I
feel like I need to make something that
you don't need to heat up to taste good
so I thought the best thing for that is
peanut butter and jelly sandwich okay so
I've got two sandwiches for ten here I
also have a secret dessert surprise that
I know he's gonna like so I know ten
often talks about wanting something
chocolaty after his meal so I got him
some sugar-free pudding I noticed that
there is a note here just like I left
although handsome fiance that's me I
hope you enjoyed this lunch it's simple
but I figured it's easy to eat during
your shoot so I never got notes in my
lunchbox as a kid but I know ten did so
what I'm gonna do is write him a note
but also provide him with the macros of
his entire lunch so he can log it super
easily into My Fitness Pal just like
that
lunch box complete this really does warm
my heart and came with a nice little
note I'm gonna keep that note gonna
bring it in the car with me paste it up
on a dashboard okay it's day two of ten
making me lunch it looks like I have
another note it's another cute one ah
masala burger is holy
I love masala burgers ya'll Ted make me
a double decker masala burger I don't
know if you guys have ever had the solid
burgers from Trader Joe's incredible he
also added my favorite cheese today
we're gonna be grilling up some masala
burgers from Trader Joe's and I happen
to know that they are one of Swansea's
favorite things this is like the best
lunch of my life so I feel like I want
to continue this because I just wanna
keep getting surprise lunches I so I
just finished up a meeting taking a
quick break before the next one and it
is lunch time so let's see what we got
today whoo that looks like mac and
cheese so I stole 10 set up for lunch
today I'm gonna be making macaroni and
cheese with broccoli and chicken and
here's the finished product pop it right
in here I also got him another
specialist snack Scooby Snacks and that
is a finished lunch for day two ready to
go is this fire this is a way better way
to eat broccoli mixed in with the mac
and cheese it's like you don't even know
is there so it's another day another
lunch by 10:00 I'm excited to see what
we have I'm gonna start with my favorite
part the note it's another good one ooh
and he made me a quesadilla today we're
gonna make something real simple simple
but one of Aussies favorite still a case
of the
lunch day 3 in the bag I'm excited this
quesadilla I love cheesy quesadillas
love cheese so I'm sure he knows that in
fact I can tell because I can see the
cheese oil soaked through this paper
towel mmm amazing I so I've been in the
studio all day recording and mixing
tracks and I'm just taking a quick break
to eat this lunch here it's actually
super helpful that Swasey made this
today otherwise I probably wouldn't have
had time to do what I have to like go
out and get something whatever so let's
see what she made ah she says we're
looking forward to hearing the new track
because she knows that I'm doing all
right so I just stepped outside real
quick to eat this and this chicken fried
rice is buyer so today 10 is gonna go
record a track with his sound engineer
and get the song mixed so I'm gonna make
something that's really easy for him to
eat while he's on the job so I'm gonna
be making him some chicken fried rice
here you can see I've got me
[Music]
chicken toss back in here I finished up
tens fried rice lunch sliding it on in
I've already thrown the pencils in this
lunch box
and for dessert I'm gonna give him some
of his favorite pudding and while this
was cooking I wrote up my note Fang
we're done
I just want to elaborate on how much is
meant to be today
you know the fact that she wrote the
note saying that hey I can't wait to
hear the new track it's just like I mean
it really just motivated the hell out of
me to just like do my best in there put
me in a real good mood the fact that
it's like written out on a note I could
just like put it up on the wall or
whatever it's pretty meaningful I would
say another week another lunch another
note this one is special because Scott
is drying off our dog passed away eight
months ago and look at how cute that is
so really fill on this note I also got
some ravioli that looks amazing
it's covered in vodka sauce I had the
idea today to make some four cheese
ravioli I know for a fact that swathi
loves ravioli my note and we're ready to
go day forward and there's cheese in
this ravioli he knows me well cooked
through amazing all right so day four it
is a rainy day here in LA I just
finished up an audition and I am stuck
oh there we go bug muffin that's like my
favorite the world one thing I can tell
you about ten is that ten loves
McDonald's loves McDonald's loves Egg
McMuffins
I figured today I would make a slightly
more macro friendly egg McMuffin
using turkey bacon alright here's the
finished McMuffin ready to go this is a
beautiful thing
why she just makes the bed so it's the
final day of our lunch challenge the
note that I have is hilarious
it looks like 10 made me some hotdogs I
so welcome back to tens kitchen day five
so today I'm gonna switch it up a little
bit
sauce thinking today like what would be
like a random thing to make and I
arrived at the idea of hotdogs all right
so these are grilling right now they
smell great while they were grilling I
took the opportunity to make my note for
today alright so as you can see here we
got to complete hotdogs ready to go day
five in the bag so I have my hot dog
he's a little moist but he looks good
quality hot dog nailing it like always
amazing last lunch Thank You ten all
right so day five taking a quick lunch
break and let's see what we got going on
today I love that spicy grilled cheese
from Ralph's I do love the spicy grilled
cheese from Ralph's today is the last
day of lunch and I'm going to be making
ten a grilled cheese sandwich using my
personal favorite chipotle mayo here's
my finished grilled cheese
here's ten sandwich and that's it for
day five
[Music]
it doesn't get better than this okay so
we just finished our week of making luck
for each other hmm I thought it was a
lot of fun I had a good time like
getting these surprise lunches and not
necessarily knowing what they were
same-same I thought it was now if I'd
actually I had a lot of fun making the
lunches and receiving them I personally
loved all the notes those are my
favorite part yes the note I think the
notes are great I have to say the notes
always brightened up my day especially
the fact that the macros are written out
fire good job thank you I would like to
the some songs stickers on I would do it
again I definitely would do it again
deftly would do it again I would
actually like another grilled cheese
great glory No
[Music]